bene successivo gli astisti avrebbe
ottenuto qualche click con lavori di sé
buona visione ciao leichhardt sexy anche
il mio team in testa xvi grazie ma come
posso ringraziarti se non mancando di
tutta la partita
[Risate]
carlos è meritata una sola merita volevo
volevo fare questa cosa per vedere se
riusciva a salvarlo lo stesso andiamo
noi non ci ha perdonato e spesso però il
centro perché è un grandissimo passaggio
bloccato che stava difensore papato
romano ma viviano su bell controllino
che controllino avvocato questa è non
entra
dopo un patto non so cosa fatto e stato
cosi temi messi bene la palla dal quadro
della patria è il papà era buono e
questo è ottimo bella bella mi nulla da
dire se non un 2 a 0 meritato degli
avversari ma che recupereremo subito dai
dai dai dai dai dai dai no noverino ci
crede un ciò caduto manco io salivo che
tanto cosa gli hai un solo spin parola
borini delle fiducia adesso elica che io
stavo andando dietro l'obiettivo per
scontato che manovrando va bene va bene
di malaga ma è la bello ha segnato pure
dentro viola salvata consiglio che gioca
nei cristalli psy tardi
e allora niente ho provato a farlo ma
potremmo insegnato io so no tutto ciò
che tiro madonna non mi aspettavo così
costosissimo un altro destra e skip va
bene appena sotto a cannes
io l'ho capito bene filo diretto e ha
perso era fei di giunta va notato che un
giorno venuto aiuta ma anche tutto ma
volevo toccarla per the best fritz lang
l'obiettivo di entrata non frega niente
ma solo perché mi ha detto che stava
entrando sono lo facevo aspetto alta
non è vero ti aspetto alta e
controlliamo notevoli non era male però
vengono poi si è dato per scontato
bella bella squadra prima della lai
avresti pregato anche aveva è stato
troppo figo perché si fregava anche a me
ha preso fai che ha detto no fantastico
dove bellissimo ma so troppo belli
ecco l'album dentro un apparato qui
sopra se solo lo sa benissimo come il
controllino ci sta mai mai mi vorrebbe
fare che cattivo
cosa succedere riuscito scartate
attenzione tutto calcolato
io sapevo che rivivono riuscita serata
tele sono riuscito perché ritoccata ii
al secolo ritoccata al telo ormai tutto
qua quindi ventata di colore funzionato
la prima volta bene alla spinta bella ma
inutile
va bene è stata divertente al di là ci
sono due persone abbastanza sfilate non
è dove dalla nome dall'avatar non so
bene poi non sarebbe il primo come è il
nostro io non ho turbo niente va bene e
giochiamo alle persone che non
colpiscono i palloni league perfetto
complimenti fa vigeva be dai cioè eccolo
che non è vero sono strana missato è
stato tradotto a mister è vendicato la
morte
non per niente pensione niente coloro
non ce la fa non ce la fa bampa tutto
madonna la palla lì proprio lui è ok
ciao ciao non forzerò attenzione già
fatta meno male che col che gole ragione
va bene barcellona contro non mi ricordo
come ci chiamiamo perché non so giocare
contro vedeva appunto il mezzo
ma che bella parata su un colpettino su
va bene così arrivato io su tre trofei
qui quello va bene va bene va bene va
bene va bene praticamente non
centotrenta malissimo erano turbo niente
perché non ce lo prendiamo vista tengo
dato vai vai se si sente di intenti al
calcio e non lo sa così sì sì lui è un
fenomeno così bravo ok dribbling e gli
scatti che lui e addio cosa cosa vedo
cosa è successo la facciata che gol di
legale la cosa poiché con la fiaba
perché gol abbiamo fatto certo per un
pincio prima dopo il pincha posto ma poi
da un'azione che non aveva un senso di
esistere cerami e mac os locali sono
bellissimi era bellissima
ma l'aspetto sacrale anche loro nome
peccato ma tu era un pc voluto no perché
io ho pensato di vincerla poi detto non
so come si fa avanti ho visto mi sono
messo in questi sottomissione e nessuna
paura che vuole sacco quando lo via
bellissimo non pesa un po troppo
anatomista invece troppo
ok questo cuore non tengono youtube ma
ci cresce più neanche lui non c'è
neanche l'altro contro in quello però in
mezzo ha spinto loro spendono siamo
doppio fake steve proteico trofei top
il tutto con brutto lo spino spin senso
abbandonato beta una chiusura predicato
conferma aspettando il bus come i prof
bravo bravo ok lo bloccano blocchi per
sentiva dire erano messi però la palla è
lì che bella brava sara su tutt'altro
cariolato primo tempo che york times
brother perché mi arriva lo zio ma
niente come cattivo lord sono non ci
sono 61 le morisco allora l'altro che la
pato ma quando tutti e si capitali
esteri
ne avranno odiato tantissimo tipo non ha
lasciata attiva di miss e mi hanno
cristiana tandoi neanche io sono stato
attivo aspetto aspetto sembra di no
la chiusura si sta aprendo le loro buste
paga l'ici non va bene per la
vecchissima bene proprio luglio non ho
segnato sta attirando così l'attenzione
forse c'è ancora l'ultima possibilità di
retro dovrà controllarla
magari se mi tolgo dalle palle vabbè che
faccio la dis rapido con laurini su
rocked league se poi vi sia piaciuto
spero che sia un vostro gradimento
questi video infatti lasciatevi mi piace
perché dai vi piace lo capisco
iscrivetevi al canale e noi come sempre
ci diamo al prossimo vino e le ragazze
[Musica]